I guess just to start off were you ever
as terrorising as the children in this
movie when you were a kid in different
ways yeah I I snuck out all the time and
I I smoked when I was like nine like
snuck out and drove my mother's car I
get cigarettes at 9:00 my mother is
asleep I grab her cigarettes grab her
car head out go pick up my friends at
9:00 mmm I didn't drive at 9:00 but I
was like smoking and then I started
sneaking out the car probably when I was
14 that's impressive
I mean did you crash the car at all or
no that's really good I mean I got your
resume okay I got caught many times but
I still it didn't stop me I was getting
ascended your parents keep you in line
but I remember one time I I was going to
a Pat Benatar concert and I was supposed
to be in trouble at home and and it was
like I got the tickets of Pat Benatar
ahead now my mother was like you are not
you're staying and I was like goodbye
yeah Pat Benatar's in town I was just
gonna say my friends pulled up I got in
the car and just went and saw Pat
Benatar what did their parents do when
when you came home that night I just I
wish you had done that you know have you
learned any tactics now that you're a
parent like how you're gonna handle this
I wonder there's moments where you know
my kids are there almost two and a half
and so there's moments where they need
to be disciplined but the only
discipline they're getting is no you
shouldn't do that and so I always ask
Stephanie I'm like our wait is this
discipline like what do what are we
supposed to do oh don't do that's that's
not for you wow that you know it seems
like when does it escalate to wear
something major is happening where
they're really I mean they get upset
because they want to watch Peppa Pig
which is their favorite show and I don't
know nothing it's just family of pigs
that are you know there's always some
lesson do you watch it with them or yeah
I love it
okay it's such a great show it's pigs
with English accents okay and I highly
recommend it
did you learning tactics from this film
potentially what wouldn't you do did you
learn things you would not do from this
movie I don't think I would show up at
my kids school and start yelling okay at
someone else's child mm-hmm
like mark you know and Rose dead sure I
at that point I was like yeah that's not
my style like yeah did you do any
research into sort of adoption agencies
in foster care I mean I went on my own
one I'm a single because I was
interested in adoption and then I have a
friend that's a social worker and I have
friends that went through the foster dot
system in Los Angeles and got a very
close view of it all when they went
through the process and they luckily now
have legally adopted their daughter but
I would say I went into the movie with a
good amount of information I didn't feel
like I was walking into the complete
unknown especially since I went on my
own accord for my own personal reasons
you